so we're now at Christmas 2010 and it's
been an exciting year for chemistry new
elements new molecules and next year
2011 is going to be even more exciting
because it's the International Year of
chemistry chemists all over the world
are going to be celebrating the joys of
chemistry the excitement of chemistry
and trying to bring this to young people
to the public all over the world and
I've got special time already from the
International Year of chemistry covered
with messages all in the same message
but in different languages chemistry our
life our future we've thought really
hard what we want to do for the
International Year of chemistry so what
we want to do is to help you understand
the language that binds chemists
together so we're going to have some
very short videos called chem definition
which will tell you about all these
words that we use of course we're still
going to do all our other videos this is
an extra something to help you enjoy the
year of chemistry I just like on behalf
of the whole periodic video team to
thank you for your support your
enthusiasm for your messages and say
that we really enjoy communicating with
you and we hope 2011 the year of
chemistry is going to be really exciting
for us all